Чесно кажучи знаєте мене вже дістали оці
От такі пафосні постопорожні заявочки
починаючи від того що ми вже по
позавчора зайшли в Крим і виграли війну
і завершуючи тим що в нас в нас все
добре тільки Порошенко заважає або там
не так американці на нас дивляться або
не так нам снаряди дають передовсім
треба брати на себе відповідальність
якщо ви не здатні працювати на державу о
тоді дійсно треба уряд національної
навіть не єдності сьогодні треба уряд
національного порятунку і оскільки
президент у нас є лю скажемо так особою
яка легітимізує державу в стані війни то
мені видається що зараз найдієвішим було
би поміняти уряд на уряд національного
порятунку і тут питання в компетентних
людях які здатні робити щось і здатні
брати на себе відповідальність і зміна
керівництва парламенту тому що те що
зараз є це явно не керівництво не
парламенту і не демократичної держави